with hours to go before Parliament is
suspended another defeat for the
government with an order to reveal all
private messages between advisers about
that decision along with assessments of
the damage and No Deal brexit will cause
then the leader of the Opposition on his
feet opening a debate about whether
Boris Johnson will abide by the new law
making him ask the EU to extend the
brexit deadline unless there's a deal we
are not at war the Prime Minister seems
obsessed with this hyperbole and
aggressive language surrender bill or do
and die or Corbin went on to call for
healing not widening divisions in the UK
and these were only the sideshows on a
gray Monday in Westminster with more in
store the expected defeat of a second
attempt from the Prime Minister to call
an election due to be followed by the
suspension of Parliament for five weeks
earlier Johnson had been in Dublin
trying to talk up the prospects of a
brexit deal but there was a flat
response from his Irish counterpart lee
/ ad Carr who said it will be a
Herculean task to get a deal through at
this stage the focus here is on the
backstop the insurance policy to avoid a
hard UK EU border between Northern
Ireland and Ireland Johnson has
suggestions on alternatives but there
are no prospects of an agreement right
now I want to get a deal like you I've
looked carefully at No Deal I've
assessed its consequences both for our
country and yes of course we could do it
the UK could certainly get through it
but be in no doubt that outcome would be
a failure of statecraft for which we
would all be responsible the backstop
continues to be a critical component of
the withdrawal agreements unless and
until alternatives are found but we are
open to alternatives but they must be
realistic ones legally binding and
workable and we haven't received such
proposals to date with a suspension of
parliament
you late on Monday night the opposition
here has done all it can in the time
available to prevent a No Deal brexit
there's no doubt an election is coming
but short of breaking the law or
actually getting a deal Johnson doesn't
look like going to the polls in the
timeframe he wants Andrew Symonds
al Jazeera Westminster